bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 votre rendez vous avec l
actualité locale du lundi au jeudi en
direct de 18 à 19 heures et pour ce
premier plateau ce soir je reçois
frédéric ballmer bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur des écoles petits bilingues
également anne capio bonsoir
maire-adjointe en charge notamment de la
réussite scolaire sur cette ville
d'elancourt en cours d'édition tout à
l'heure nous rejoindre à jack
bouthillier professeur des universités
directeur de l'institut des langues et
des études internationales de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et nous parlerons de
l'apprentissage de l'anglais à quel âge
faut-il commencer et puis également
autour de cette table
aurélia domicile bonsoir aurélia masse à
la page culture comme chaque mercredi
dorénavant avec vous ce sera dans une
demie tout à fait donc ce soir nous
aborderons comment apprendre le français
pour les étrangers
après l'anglais ou apprendre le français
exactement et cette fois ci au travers
de la musique mais ce sera une chronique
pas seulement musical
il y aura également des petites
surprises regardez les surprises power
tout à l'heure aurélia pour l'instant
nous passons au titre en images les
sujets à suivre donc
ce soir bien respecter le rythme des
enfants attrapent c'est une
problématique qui interpellent les
responsables de la petite enfance avec
ce constat les assistantes maternelles
ne sont pas souvent assez bien formés à
ces questions faire aimer la littérature
à à tous les publics
éveiller le sens critique forum
départemental à ce mercredi
aujourd'hui à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin regroupant des
lycéens des filières professionnelles
ils ont pu rencontrer des auteurs et en
débattre avec eux le funk ses origines
son état d'esprit la ville de guyancourt
fait revivre les années soixante dix au
travers d'une exposition bien plus
qu'une musique le funk est aussi un
moyen d'expression majeur pour la
communauté noire colline elle ouvert
utilise des matériaux et des végétaux
pour créer des oeuvres l'artiste à son
atelier à chevreuse elle expose jusqu'au
28 février
médiathèque de voisins le bretonneux son
travail sera à découvrir tout à l'heure
donc au cours de la page culture les
rythmes scolaires un sujet d'actualité
avec la préparation d'une loi vous le
savez autour de ce sujet bientôt le
retour est d'une semaine à quatre jours
et demi
mais plus globalement ces réflexions
intéresse aussi bon nombre d'acteurs de
la petite enfance quel est le rythme
idéal pour les enfants attrapent une
réunion sur le sujet vient d'avoir lieu
valérie auribeau et guillon campent pour
les explications si petit et déjà au
coeur des débats
samedi dernier la ville de trappes
organisait son premier rendez vous entre
professionnels de la petite enfance et
par an l'occasion d'échanger sur les
rythmes et les espaces de vie du jeune
enfant
je travaille en crèche et c'est vrai que
c'était un travail intéressant par
rapport à mon travail au niveau des
enfants et c'est vrai que ça nous fait
beaucoup de rappel aussi sur ce qu'on a
appris avant qu'ils vont se rend compte
que c'est loin d'être la réalité un
personnel trop peu nombreux pour
accueillir toujours plus d'enfants et
c'est la liberté d'épanouissement des
tout petits qui se trouve amputée de
plus auxiliaire animateurs et
assistantes maternelles sont trop peu
formés à l'éducation des 0 6 ans ce
recul est dû de faire une formation
collective
entre différents services ça peut être
intéressant
on est tous là même pédagogique la même
démarche
les avis des enfants respecter le rythme
de l'enfant à ses intérêts et faire tout
ça soit en même temps pour faire une
activité c'est pas forcément bon laisser
l'enfant jouer et être initiateurs de
son jeu pour lui donner confiance en lui
plutôt que d'être encadré et orienté par
les adultes
c'est le souhait des professionnels
présents ce jour là la france est en
retard sur certaines des questions en
tout cas sur l'éducation et sur le fait
de
laissez les plus petits jouer le plus
longtemps possible dès qu'ils
franchissent dirait
la porte de l'école en fait ils sont
formatés pour pouvoir répondre aux
demandes des enseignants et de pouvoir
être préparés pour leur enseignement ils
deviennent très tôt des élèves changer
les modes d'accueil des enfants et les
individualiser ce sont les pistes de
travail de la ville de trappes qui
propose d'autres débats tout au long du
mois de février
jacques petit professeur des universités
directeur de l'institut des langues et
des études internationales de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous a donc
rejoint bonsoir à vous merci de venir
sur ce plateau vous êtes pile à l'heure
pour évoquer l apprentissage de
l'anglais durant les prochaines minutes
pour bien comprendre ce sujet un chiffre
tout d'abord est 17 la france arrive 17e
sur 44 pays de par son niveau en anglais
l'étude d'éducation first société
d'enseignement linguistique porte en
effet sur 44 pays à travers le monde où
l'anglais n'est pas la langue maternelle
comment expliquer ce mauvais résultat ce
mauvais chiffre
17e sur 44 comment ça s'explique
pourquoi les français sont si mauvais
dans l'apprentissage des langues et
l'anglais par contre que cela te faut
être tout à fait c'est bon vous faites
votre autocritique alors oui il faut
commencer par ça mais bon il ya sûrement
des tas de raisons diverses
il ya les dans les conditions
d'enseignement de l'anglais dans les
collèges dans les lycées des grandes
classes ou l'anglais considéré comme une
matière comme une autre où les langues
d'ailleurs c'est le peuple anglais
considéré comme une matière comme une
autre or l'anglais ou les langues c'est
quelque chose qui a à voir avec quelque
chose de très intime après tout on
apprend sa langue maternelle à partir de
avant même de détenez paraît-il donc
on l'apprend avant même d'être né parce
que justement apprendre une langue
étrangère scellier ou à l'accoutumance à
des sonorités donc il est tout un
mécanisme de qui relève du corps
finalement c'est pas seulement un
apprentissage de savoir ou de
compétences comme peuvent l'être
d'autres matières frédéric van der veer
également comment vous voyez la
situation vous êtes le directeur des
écoles des petits bilingues
c'est un établissement qui va ouvrir son
48e 49e centre sur la ville d'elancourt
prochainement
c'est également pour ça que vous êtes
venus ce soir sur le plateau comment
vous l'expliquez vous ce mauvais
résultat c'est ça il faudrait parler d
avant même la naissance de l'enfant par
exemple en volume en les dernières
études scientifiques montrent que ces
mêmes avant la naissance de l'enfant ce
sont dans les trois derniers mois de la
grossesse que le foetus commence déjà à
être imprégné de la rythmicité de la
musicalité de sa longue et c'est sur la
base d'ailleurs de ces études
scientifiques que nous même au niveau
des petits bilingues
nous avons mis en place il ya un peu
moins de deux ans de cela et un an au
niveau de notre déploiement national à
une dynamique d'apprentissage une
pédagogie tout spécialement orientée
vers l'enfant dès l'âge de 1 an
maintenant
parce qu'effectivement l'enfant j'ai
envie de dire presque plus il est jeune
plus il est doué pour l'apprentissage
des langues et j'ai aussi envie de
parler d'un ton presque mozart c'est à
dire que l'enfant avant 7 ans parce que
physiologiquement au niveau de ses
muscles audio et vocaux il n'est pas
encore mature il est doué d'un potentiel
extraordinaire vu de la vision d'un
adulte il est quasiment totipotentes et
c'est pour ça que je parlerai presque de
l'enfant mozart est donc cette première
période de vie entre 0 et 7 ans eh bien
il faut l'utiliser au maximum parce que
l'anglais est une des clés évidente
indispensable incontournable pour une
vie professionnelle active
j'ai envie de dire demain évident mais
dès aujourd'hui à chaque fois tiens je
vous voyais acquiescé par rapport à ce
qui a été dit mais apprendre dès la
non c'est pas perturbant pour les
mécanismes du cerveau par exemple pour
un bon enfant d'entendre parler deux
langues il va assimiler parfaitement les
deux c'est un petit peu étonnant mais
apparemment oui ça fonctionne on est sa
paresse apparaît pas rationnel mais
effectivement c'est comme ça que c'est
comme ça qu'on constate que ça
fonctionne avec les enfants qui sont
exposés à ce genre d'expérience donc ça
fonctionne effectivement je ne savais
pas qu'on pouvait pousser jusqu'à
septembre j'avais gardé
je vais garder plutôt la limite des 3
ans et je pensais qu'à partir de 3 ans
ça commençait déjà à se bloquer un petit
peu au niveau auditifs donc mais en
l'initiative est effectivement
complètement dans le bon sens
je suis désolé nous à l'université on
intervient beaucoup trop tard 110 pour
les élèves d'un an vous en avez
finalement assez collé du côté des
universités ont fait beaucoup de choses
à l'égard des scolaires aussi pendant
les pendant les vacances mais même les
scolaires je m'en vais avec lesquels on
intervient ont quand même déjà 13 14 15
ans parce que tout est effectivement un
travail qui est mené pour les un peu
plus grand du côté de l'université de
versailles saint quentin sur
l'apprentissage des langues notamment de
l'anglais qui nous intéresse ce soir un
capuchon je me tourne vers vous
également vous êtes maire-adjointe
d'elancourt en charge de la réussite
scolaire alors sans rentrer dans un
conflit autour de cette refondation de
l'école en plus y aurait forcément
beaucoup de choses à dire mais ça les
nôtres on n'est pas tout de même un peu
dans un échec du système dans la façon
d'appréhender l'apprentissage des
langues par exemple il fallait repenser
la chose et c'est pour ça que vous avez
décidé de faire appel à une autre
structure qui va ouvrir en marge de
l'école c'est en plus pour les parents
qui voudront s'y inscrire eh bien oui
puisque nous depuis à peu près dix ans
maintenant sur elancourt
le maire jean michel fourgous a mis en
place un improbable à un programme
d'école numérique qui est maintenant
très connu et en fait le l'accueil des
petits bilingues sur l encours est un
peu la continuité de notre programme
d'école numérique un récent sondage sur
elle en cours montrent que les allemands
courtois ont plébiscité la la la
réussite scolaire en troisième point
après la sécurité et l'emploi
donc c'est une prairie une préoccupation
première
l'anglais est une compétence avec le
numérique qui va être demandé aux
enfants évidemment de plus en plus dans
leur milieu professionnel
et l'anglais est évidemment une
compétence majeure dans les écoles
actuellement nous avons mis en place les
cours d'anglais par visioconférence mais
on croit beaucoup à la pédagogie mixte
qui est une pédagogie en classe et hors
classe est donc l'accueil des petits
bilingues va permettre aux élans
courtois de pouvoir avoir un service
d'apprentissage de la langue
supplémentaire à ce qu'ils étaient à
skis et les cours qui sont donnés
pendant l'école mais j'ai quand même
faire une parenthèse ce sera forcément
ouvert pour des familles qui ont les
moyens d'inscrire leur enfant
effectivement les tarifs vont varier en
fonction de des formules choisies que ce
soit un stage pour les week-ends que ce
soit une inscription est tout au long de
l'année sur une trentaine d'heures à peu
près 1 dispensés sur l'année mais il
faut tout même inscrire ses enfants et
ce à un coût supplémentaire alors déjà
allé dans le partenariat que nous avons
monté avec les petits bilingues
il y à un tarif préférentiel qui est
réservé aux élans courtois ainsi qu'une
priorité d'inscription pour les élans
courtois et à l'intérieur de notre
partenariat
les petits bilingues ont eu cette super
idée d'offrir à la ville d'elancourt
cinq places toutes les cinquante
inscriptions et nous c'est cinq places
là on les réservera bien sûr à des
familles qui sont en difficulté et pour
leur permettre aussi d'avoir parce
qu'ils n'auront pas à payer
l'inscription de leurs enfants et c'est
pour nous un excellent un excellent
moyen de 2 d'égalité des chances et
d'accès à tous à l'apprentissage de
l'anglais à l'école des petits bilingues
qui va ouvrir ce mois ci d'ici la fin du
mois après les vacances en tout cas de
mars ça c'est sûr du côté de la ville
d'elancourt ce sera dans les locaux de
l'ancienne école privée sainte-thérèse
justement qui a voilà et ménagers
d'aujourd'hui dans des nouveaux locaux
on avait d'ailleurs parlé sur cette
antenne l'école qui n'est pas ouverte
uniquement aux élans courtois et la
courtoise et surtout ouvert à toute la
population qui voudra bien s'y rendre on
va juste faire une petite pause pour
justement allez vous poser cette
question écouter vos réponses apprenez
vous l'anglais à vos enfants avez vous
déjà de bons réflexes
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de
l'anglais partout tout le temps
l'accord voyage oui je le referais
apprendre des langues pas nécessairement
l'anglais je pense qu'il faut un peu
lutté contre sept
cet automatisme de faire apprendre
l'anglais nos enfants il ya de trop
longues utile comme chinois l'allemand
japonais
la lys pagnol oui enfin je pensais à
l'école après oui ça me paraît pas mal
parce que comme ça aurait internationale
j'utilise partout donc oui je dire 11 en
sixième
parce que ça fait beaucoup 10 6 ans et
paiement cp on a déjà du mal à parler le
français n'ont que mon sens qu ils font
d'habitude paraît très bien et je pense
que les premières années sont les plus
importantes pour les pour la plupart des
choses importantes dans la vie et
notamment pour le languedoc qui est très
utile de nos jours tout le monde fait le
même constat il faut apprendre l'anglais
il ya des efforts qui sont faits on
verra dans quelques années si
effectivement ça ces efforts ont porté
leurs fruits à partir de quel âge en
tout cas c'est perdu les jeunes que vous
accueillez les moins jeunes que vous
accueillez à l'université ce n'est je me
tiens tu sais aussi ce que je voulais
entendre ce soir pour assurer pour ceux
qui ne maîtrisent pas l'anglais riki
qu'affirme pas forcément entre 1 et 12
ans
la difficulté c'est surtout au niveau de
l'oral de la prononciation puisque on va
reconstituer ce qu'on entend bien il se
trouve que l'oreille et paresseuse et
dans les six tout simplement ça dans les
premiers temps de l'apprentissage
l'oreille est paresseuse et elle
comprend dans son environnement
qu'est ce qu'il est important de garder
et si elle entend que du français elle
garde les fréquences du français qui
sont complètement différentes se tourne
comme ça des fréquences de l'anglais
dans leur travail et comment alors avec
les étudiants que vous recevez dans
votre sens
il a aussi aidé mais effectivement
pardon il ya des méthodes pour essayer
de se rééduquer l'oreille justement à
percevoir les fréquences de l'anglais
britannique et ou de l'anglais américain
qui sont pas d'ailleurs tout à fait le
même
donc on a des méthodes pour sam est donc
ce n'est pas sérieux nous l'avait dit
c'est le message regardez bien ça n'est
pas du tout perdu mais c'est vrai que
c'est plus facile si on s'y prend très
tôt et comment vous faites alors à
partir de 1 an comment vous apprenez
l'anglais à ses enfants de 1 an et ça
n'aurait pas marché
déjà comme nous l'avions de le dire
monsieur nous les exposons un
environnement sonore natif donc avec des
anglo saxons et cette exposition à cet
environnement sonore plus l'enfant est
jeune plus il est naturel c'est à dire
que l'espoir n'est jamais perdu mais par
contre
plus on avance en âge plus l'effort va
être considérable va être considérable
le jeune enfant
ça va être une sorte de perméabilité
naturel perméabilité magique donc sur
enfants de 1 à 3 ans effectivement nous
allons les exposer à cette musicalité à
cette rythmicité et à partir de 3 ans
avec la prise de conscience progressive
de l'an de l'enfant dans son
environnement
nous allons par des activités est
totalement adapté à son âge lui
permettre de faire de l'anglais
finalement sans s'en rendre compte donc
ce sont des activités au sein d'un
groupe d'enfants
dix enfants en moyenne qui vont partager
par écart d'âge de 1 an maximum donc
deux ans par deux ans qu'ils vont
partager quatre à six activités par
atelier toutes ces activités et emmenée
par une anglo saxonne avec cette lente
de partage qui est l'anglais donc ils
vont faire de l'anglais sont sans
apercevoir ce que nous allons essayer de
leur donner c'est surtout le plaisir est
là j'ai envie de dire que le plaisir
c'est un des vecteurs en termes
d'efficacité d'apprentissage le plus
important et on va rétablir les
équilibres qui là est aussi efficace est
aussi essentielle chez l'adulte que chez
l'enfant
donc notre première démarche ça va être
d'un stylet ce plaisir au niveau de ces
groupes et que ses enfants au fur à
mesure qu'ils vont grandir acquiert cet
amour de la langue anglo saxon cet
intérêt pour la culture anglo saxonne
qui fait aussi totalement partie et est
au coeur de notre pédagogie de façon à
ce que à partir de 12 ans lorsqu'ils
vont rentrer dans des systèmes plus
académique non seulement qu'il se
retrouve avec un avantage considérable
par rapport à cette compréhension par
rapport à cette oreille que sites est
monsieur mais également avec cette
dynamique de l'an viii du plaisir
d'apprendre l'anglais parce qu'ils
auront compris que l'anglais est la clé
d'accès à un monde un monde
international arich et évidemment
passionnant attend votre cinquantaine de
centres environ dix mille enfants
parents qui parce qu'ils sont inscrits
qui suivent ces cours une trentaine
d'heures donc au cours de l'année
scolaire
environ 5000 c'est ce que vous me disiez
également et qui participent aux stages
de vacances donc uniquement durant hors
période hors période scolaire
de tout ça concrètement un enfant qui
rentre qui ne s'est pas du tout parlé
anglais il s'exprimer couramment à la
fin du stage à la fin de l'année alors à
la fin du stage
certainement pas si en particulier c'est
son premier stage comment la jugez en
tout cas l'évolution et la réussite d'un
stage ou d'une année d'inscription alors
nous le jugeons par tout un ensemble
d'indicateurs c'est à dire que le
premier des indicateurs et cette
interactivité permanente c'est à dire
que à chaque âge va être voulons être
fixé des objectifs précis et qui vont
toujours amener l'enfant à participer
davantage au sein du groupe est au coeur
des activités
donc le très jeune enfant évidemment ça
va être beaucoup plus une imprégnation
en termes d'oreilles en termes de
capacité de restitution progressive de
son monsieur a indiqué tout à l'heure
que les sons de la langue anglaise sont
très différents de ceux de la langue
française et ceci explique en partie
cela et que l'oreille devient paresseuse
donc nous nous allons travailler cette
oreille de l'enfant de façon à ce
qu'elle ne se ferme pas et de façon à ce
que l'enfant puisse justement capter
l'anglais très exactement comme sa
langue maternelle
ensuite au fur et à mesure qu'il va
grandir et bien nous allons mesurer
cette interactivité dans sa capacité
d'expression au sein du groupe dans sa
capacité de questionnement par rapport
au groupe est donc finalement dans des
échanges qui deviennent de plus en plus
sûres incomparable avec le monde adulte
c'est à dire simplement de prise de
connaissance de l'autre de capacité
d'expliquer de restituer son
environnement et de partage et
d'échangés ce qui est le principe ce qui
est le moteur même des langues et ce
sont ses activités ses activités plaisir
qu'ils vont être le vecteur de cet
apprentissage vous parliez des langues
justement et pas uniquement de l'anglais
vous travaillé autour de l'anglais avec
ses enfants mais jacques pothier il
faudrait faire la même chose sur
l'ensemble des langues
justement ça fait beaucoup de courses
auxquelles inscrire ses enfants le week
end ils vont pas saturer faut faire des
choix je pense oui sûrement mais je
pense que de toute façon
les gammes de fréquences sont
différentes suivant les langues mais
d'une certaine manière si on a coutume
l'oreille à l'anglais et aux français ça
couvre déjà un large spectre dans
laquelle vont aussi se loger les autres
langues
donc ils apprennent par la suite on
perçoit réceptif à l'allemand à
l'espagnol j'imagine enfin j'imagine que
des études qui plus précises qui ont été
faites mais d'expérience c'est vrai
qu'on sait que c'est la première langue
étrangère qui coûtait après avec chaque
langue nouvelle ça devient plus facile
anne-k pions pour conclure ce plateau
l'école des petits bilingues va
s'installer sur la ville d'elancourt je
redonne la date des portes ouvertes si
on aura plusieurs mais la première date
c'est le 16 février pour voir un petit
peu comment ça fonctionne et et prendre
un premier contact
ensuite il aura des échanges avec
d'autres structures de la ville avec des
écoles de la ville également c'est le
but tout à fait après les les
on pourra étendre ce partenariat à
l'intérieur des écoles peut être
organiser des stages avec nos
enseignants pour leur apprendre diverses
techniques d'apprentissage pour les
jeunes les jeunes enfants et puis
peut-être aussi au sein de nos centres
de loisirs parce qu apprendre l'anglais
ça peut être aussi un plaisir et ça peut
être un loisir et c'est bien ce qu'on
entend faire dans nos centres de loisirs
l'école d'elancourt des petits bilingues
qui va ouvrir d'ici la fin du mois porte
est ouverte dès le 16 février puis pour
les plus grands l'institut d'études de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci donc à
nos trois intervenants de ce soir la
suite du cette suite de ce 6 février
toujours en direct jusqu'à 19 heures
avec une séquence consacrée aux
violences morales un débat autour de ce
thème va se tenir à voisins le
bretonneux et puis la page culture avec
notamment la possibilité de re découvrir
les origines du funk ça se passe du côté
de guyancourt pour l'instant éducation
toujours faire aimer la littérature à
tous les publics
éveiller le sens critique un forum
départemental vient d'avoir lieu à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et qui regroupait des lycéens des
filières professionnelles
ils ont pu rencontrer des auteurs et
débattre également avec regarder ce
mercredi matin près 250 lycéens des
yvelines ont débattu à propos de
littérature dans le cadre du forum
départemental du prix littéraire des
lycéens apprentis et stagiaires
la formation professionnelle d'île de
france une nouvelle étape pour la maison
des écrivains et de la littérature de
paris à l'origine de cette deuxième
édition
en collaboration avec la maison de la
poésie de saint quentin en yvelines
on essaye de sensibiliser les élèves à
cette littérature adulte de création
littéraire récente on essaye de les
faire rencontrer les auteurs de les
faire mettre en dialogue avec eux de
s'interroger d'être dans un argumentaire
aussi pour découvrir un livre une
écriture est aussi découvrir les métiers
les espaces du livre la sélection
yvelines comporte trois romans un
recueil de poésie est une bande dessinée
graphique
un projet qui court sur une année
scolaire et qui au début a rebuté
certains élèves
au départ le projet leur a fait un petit
peu peur parce que lire de la
littérature contemporaine un petit peu
difficile ça leur paraissait difficile
et puis le projet leur a fait peur aussi
peut-être parce qu'elles ont voulu
reconduire des des schémas de travail
qu'elle faisait au collège et quand on
leur a expliqué qu'il fallait qu'elles
jugent elles ont été un petit peu
déroutés finalement les élèves se sont
investis et ont même pris goût à
l'exercice
trop de références historiques une
écriture qui casse les codes sans
ponctuation du sarcasme et un côté
fantastique plaisant voici quelques unes
des remarques entendues au début j'ai
pris congo parce que je suis congolaise
et je pensais qu'il parlerait du congo
congo
sauf que comme il ya deux congo et ben
il parlait pas de mon congo donc va j'ai
pas accroché à cause de ça et qui en
plus j'aime pas trop défense qui comme
il parle de la colonisation c'est bien
mais moi ça me ça m'intéresse pas donc
je paye mais les dossiers choisi formose
parce que formose ya pas beaucoup
d'écrits d'écriture prochaine étape
déterminé par un système de vote
individuelle un lauréat
il sera dévoilé lors du salon du livre
de paris qui se déroulera du 22 au 25
mars porte de versailles